- Never done nothing weird
like I dipped it in the,
the Indomie juice or nothing, soggy bread.
(both laughing)
- Oh Lord!
Someone's gotta do that though innit?
Just to get that extra padding
- Nah, I don't do that you know.
May you can do that.
- Nah, I'm just saying that, maybe.
- That's how you get the runs.
- That's disgusting, don't ever do that.
And I have never done that.
Hi. I'm Gena and I'm here
with comedian Mo Gilligan
and these are his Netflix Nine.
- My first question to
you, from your Twitter
it seems like you're a
pretty big fan of Netflix.
What is it like going from
tweeting about what you're
gonna watch on Netflix,
what everyone else has watched on Netflix
to knowing that you'll be
able to watch your own show?
- Do you know how I
put it on my Instastory
how excited I was when I
actually typed my name in,
M-O, and I'm like going down
(Gena laughs)
Okay, left, right, G-I,
and it wasn't coming up
and then I put an L and I was like
"Who is this?"
It didn't say, all it had was
this like Mo Gilligan Momentum
and that in itself was exciting.
Do you know what I'm
really excited for, yeah?
You know when it starts and it goes
"Duh-dum"
- [Gena] Yeah
(both laughing)
That's me.
- I don't care about the rest of it.
- So your comedy special Momentum
it talks about a lot of different things.
You talk about teachers, you
talk about family parties,
and you also talk about getting
in trouble with your mum.
What's the worst thing you
got in trouble for as a kid?
- Okay this isn't so much a kid,
I was a bit more like a bit
of a teenager at this time
because I was eighteen or nineteen,
I burnt the kitchen down.
- Sorry
(Mo laughing, flames burning)
The entire kitchen?
- Yeah, so what happened is
my sister was coming back from work
and she phoned me and she says
"Is there any food?"
And I was like
"No, there's no food."
But I said
"If you stop off at Tesco and maybe get,"
You know you can get the
microwave curry sauce
and stuff like that, the
chicken curry, I said
"I'll make some chips and we
can curry sauce and chips"
She was like
"Okay, cool."
So I've put the chips in the frying pan
and I think I went upstairs
and I think I heard the fire alarm go off.
So in my head I was like
"Oh but I closed the
kitchen door so why this"
(Gena laughs loudly)
"what's going on there?"
So I ran downstairs and I see smoke
and we have one of those long lights,
the ones with tube,
we had one of those in the
kitchen and that melted off.
That just went "floom"
and I was like "Okay"
So I turned off the cooker
and my mom's got a parrot, called Bella
and the parrot's just looking at me
and I'm looking at the parrot
(Gena laughs loudly)
- This is the wildest story I've ever
(continues laughing)
The parrot is a plot twist, what the?
- The parrot's under the stairs
opposite the kitchen door.
I say this like everyone's got
a parrot under their stairs.
- I didn't think you were
gonna talk about a parrot!
- So, I pushed the parrot out of the cage
but the parrot is not used to like,
he hasn't seen the world innit?
So I'm crying and the parrot is just like
"what is this, this is a car?
"I've never seen a car before,
I live under the stairs"
So I had to get a blanket
and the fire brigade came
and I had to call my mum up
and I made tears before I called her,
so I called my mum
(sobbing and heavy breathing)
I worked myself up
(pretending to sob)
"I just wanna say that I luv, I love you"
and my mum's like
"What's wrong, what happened?"
- You're gonna kill me!
- And I was like
"I'm so so sorry"
(both laughing)
and then my mum was like
"What's wrong?"
I was like
(pretending to sob)
"The kitchen burnt down"
- There's also a great part in the special
where you talk about birthday
WhatsApp's that women make.
I'm actually currently in one.
- You're in a WhatsApp?
- I'm in a WhatsApp group,
specifically about a birthday.
My question is who is giving
you the intel on this?
How do you know about this stuff?
- Well, you see, I've got sisters.
So I talk about that in the special.
I pick up a lot of things,
you know I grew up in
a house full of women,
my mum, my two sisters,
kinda raised by women.
So I'd always pick up these things.
But then same things
I've got a male WhatsApp group,
where we do the same thing with birthdays
but no-one gets back.
"Yo guys, it's my birthday,
do you wanna come?"
People just leave the group.
"No I don't wanna go, you know."
And they just go!
(Both laughing)
You can't really leave a WhatsApp group,
you can't because then
people talk about you.
- Yeah, that's true.
(Mo speaks in a feminine manner)
- "She left you know, I
never liked her anyway."
- You once tweeted, and I quote
"I've got a Nandos whole
chicken on my loyalty card
"I'm gonna give it to somebody
as a Christmas present."
Did you ever gift that
second hand loyalty chicken?
- Do you know what? I don't think I did.
This was at a stage though
when I was really broke
and I was just tryna be
mad inventive of like,
imagine that as a Christmas
present where you're like
"What's this?
"It's a Nando's whole chicken"
and you're like
"hmm I'm not happy"
but it will be of good use at some stage.
When you ain't got no money,
it's not a remix gift you know.
(both laughing)
I'll buy a gift card and buy
another gift card with it.
(both laughing again)
- [Gena] So you seem to have spoken a lot
about cheese on toast online.
What's the deal with that?
Do you actually like cheese
on toast that much or?
- Do you know what it is?
When I was living at my
mum's that was the two things
that was always there.
There was always bread there.
There was always cheese there.
So it was like the go to midnight snack.
It was either that or the Indomie noodles?
You know, like them broke meals innit?
There's a lot going on,
like eating noodles.
- I was starting off like "hmm"
and then I was like "wait".
- I never done nothing weird
like I dipped it in the Indomie
juice or nowt, soggy bread.
(both laughing)
- Oh Lord!
Someone's gotta do that though innit,
just to get that extra
padding in the stomach.
- Nah I don't do that you
know, may be you can do that.
- No I've never done that,
just saying that, maybe.
- Sometimes you do that
but, I didn't do that.
- No, no, what I meant was like, you know,
if that's something that is
done I wouldn't judge it.
- That's how you get the runs.
- That's disgusting, don't ever do that.
And I have never done that.
(clears throat)
What is on your Netflix list right now?
- Oh, what's on my Netflix list?
Let's have a look.
I've got Mindhunter.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I've been trying
to get into this one.
It's bit slow, I'm not gonna lie,
but if there's a long flight.
- You can't slag off the show
(bursts out laughing)
- Hey I'm part of the club now innit?
- You are, you really are!
- I'm part of the club now innit?
(both laugh)
I've got the Fresh Prince.
Fresh Prince is like if I want to go,
when I'm going to bed, chuck
a bit of Fresh Prince on.
Bob Laser.
- Who?
- Bob Lazar, ah, that's
how you know I'm not.
See, I need to watch the
documentary, you know.
- It's Bob Lazar.
- Coz the way you said it as well, it's
"It's Bob Lazar, about aliens."
I'm like
"Yeah, dis ting Bob Laser!"
(both laughing)
- Me too, I was like...
- Sounds like some guy you met in the pub.
(speaks in a Cockney accent)
"I've seen aliens, yeah,
oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
"What's ya name? Bob Laser? Bob Laser!
(Gena laughs)
"If you need windows,
we'll do a double glazer"
Big ups Bob's man.
(both laughing)
- Give me your opinion
on the following things.
So it's either/or, choose one.
Beyonce or Rihanna?
- Err, Beyonce.
- Have you seen her live?
- Yeah, I've seen her three times.
- Did you did you see
the Netflix Homecoming?
- Yeah that was sick.
- Nandos or Morley's?
- Oof, err. Morley's,
it's gotta be Morley's.
- Ketchup or Mayo?
- I'm gonna say ketchup
because ketchup is like,
you can't get bad ketchup.
- Basic, tea or coffee?
- Okay, I've got into coffee recently.
I've seen this thing, called
a white chocolate mocha.
I was like
"What's this? It sounds
like white chocolate?
"There's a white chocolate tasting drink?"
I didn't know what it was but I was like
"I'm gonna get it"
So I got it and I was like
"It tastes like coffee
"but it's got this white
chocolatey taste to it.
"Tastes delicious."
So I think I'm gonna say coffee.
- You say coffee.
You're a fan of Top Boy.
- Big fan of Top Boy.
Sully or Dushane?
(sighs)
- Ah man!
- Look you're at the edge of
the cliff, Sully or Dushane.
You've gotta push one
off, you gotta keep one.
Which one you keeping?
- I think it's gotta be Dushane.
- You're keeping Dushane? Sully's dead.
- Only because me and AsherD
went to the same secondary school.
Yeah, because I'm gonna be like
"and cut!"
Come on we were at the same school man.
Like allow me innit?
"and action!"
But I'm not gonna kill you.
(Gena laughs loudly drowning out Mo)
- You also speak a lot
about your mum and dad.
Have you ever had an awkward conversation
where your mum has had to be like
"Please stop talking about my tit"
for example, because I know
you talk about that in this.
(both laughing)
Are there any moments
when they've been like
"This has gone too far"
- When I done the tour and I done the show
my mum came, innit, to the show,
so it was always a bit like
"ooh"
like, I want you to
laugh with my experience
and not laugh at my mum.
Like I don't want you to see my mum
"Ah you're Mo's mum, dat bit
about your tits was funny"
"What you doin'? That's my mum."
Like, come on.
I was just more like, but my mum's like,
you know my mum's at the
stage where she's like
"Ah Netflix, that's good.
"Yeah, I'd like a new kitchen, you know"
So I'm like
"So you want me to get you a kitchen,
is that what your tryna say?"
Right cool.
More of these tit jokes then I guess.
(both laughing)
You know the exchange?
- Yes exactly, kitchen.
So you do a lot of impressions.
Do you have a favorite one to do?
- I always go in to a
road man for no reason.
(Mo shouting loudly unintelligibly)
I used to live in Peckham, innit.
So it's become very gentrified now.
So you know like guys that are
"Hi what's going on man?"
You know the guys that
play with their hair?
"Hey what's up? Yeah,
yeah, my name's Jack.
"Yeah, I've just moved round here,
"it's like really cool isn't it?
"is that a loft bar something?"
I'm like, I love taking
the piss out of those guys.
"Yeah like I'm just, I
was working at a start-up"
What do you do in your spare time, Jack?
"Yeah, so I'm just like,
getting into hemp growing now.
I'm just growing hemp"
What?
(Gena laughs)
Growing hemp, yeah?
(someone speaks off camera quietly)
- Wait don't.
- Sorry, did I hit your soul?
(laughter)
- I did actually think that, I was like
"He's from Peckham, it's him, it's him!"
(laughter)